you've missed a lot of the party the
worldwide tour yeah i did yeah so how
does it feel to be back with everybody
it feels it feels so great we're here in
los angeles it's a thrill to be here
it's the third time we've done a big
jurassic premiere here and i'm just
thrilled thrilled to be here i mean you
have many big premieres coming up will
you miss the dinosaurs and especially
because you've got young ones who love
dinosaurs right i listen i'm doing
everything i can to drink up every
single second of this because i know
that
this is an incredible blessing to be
here will i miss it i'm certain i will
but uh i'm not going to spend a second
of this present moment thinking about
i'm just going to try to be here and be
in it you know what i mean because it's
obviously a very special night how is
that duty going because this is a
special time in fatherhood it is like
the moment where you're like i smell
that oh boy let me change it's like
going from it's like going from zero to
60 in no seconds at a home it's really
kind of zero which i love
it's like i've shifted into a gear that
feels so nice i'm at home with mama and
uh
and babies and and it's just fantastic
man i love it and then to be here it's
like wait what happened two seconds ago
change of diapers and here i am but i
love it that time goes by so fast too
when they're that tiny right
yeah it does it time it time flies and
kids have an amazing way of making you
slow down and appreciate little things
my my daughter lila is is uh 22 months
now and i've kind of
spent a lot more time with her now than
mama's with a new baby eloise and so i'm
just out like looking at snails and
leaves and grass and playing with
bubbles the other day i had like a
two-hour session on bubbles i was like
they are amazing it's been a long i'm 42
years old bubbles man that's where it's
at bubbles are incredible aren't they
incredible and we shot this thing in a
bubble yes you did and you know what i
heard bryce was kind of like the covid
overseer the police as far as yeah
she was pretty strict on the coveted
rules i mean the protocols were being
put in place and it was hey you know
look
no one wants to talk about covid what we
want to talk about is going out to the
movies again for the first time in a
long time
it's time man it's time to get out there
we got we got the vaccines we're ready
to go we you know
can feel comfortable being out in the
theater finally after all these years
and it's awesome chris this is your last
go-round but it was a great go-around
how much fun did you have making this
movie how much fun do you have making
these movies yes making these because
you're a lot of oh and a lot of
and a lot you know it's like asking how
how exciting is it to work at the red
bull factory
you know you're like well no i know it
gives you wings when you drink it
but making it you know a lot of red bull
going by every day so it's you know it's
a lot of fun to be here but doing the
movie it was eight long months of
incredibly arduous work granted we got
to ride some horses we got to run from
some real dinosaurs we got to work with
some amazing actual animatronic
dinosaurs and i got to spend time with
jeff goldblum and laura dern and sam
neil so i'm goofing around it was
actually very fun
[Music]